en el barrio los pumitas se respira con
temor
calle solitarias fachadas con impactos
de bala son secuelas de lo que ha
conllevado el enfrentamiento entre
pandillas narcotraficantes fue aquí en
el norte de la ciudad argentina de
Rosario donde Maximiliano un niño de 11
años Fue asesinado por una bala perdida
durante un tiroteo entre dos bandas del
lugar
el seguro
pero nunca
su residentes han presenciado el aumento
del tráfico de estupefacientes en
pequeñas escala así como el de la
violencia ante la falta de presencia
Estatal los vecinos han decidido tomar
sus propias medidas demoliendo la casa
de un presunto traficante unas acciones
por las que recibieron amenazas
consistían en llamadas telefónicas y
también
personales personalmente de que el club
iba a estar sembrado de muerto y bueno
pero también Nosotros tomamos la
decisión de seguir
que nosotros estamos convencidos que
hasta la otra parte sabe que lo que
nosotros hacemos Es correcto la
desolación de los pumitas contrasta con
otros sectores de la ciudad con un
enorme Puerto Rosario es la puerta de la
agroexportación vital para el país pero
también se ha vuelto un punto de salida
de drogas hacia Europa y Asia el mercado
de mercancías ilegales que maneja el
narcotráfico
ha permitido digamos un desarrollo
exponencial del mercado inmobiliario
también por ejemplo de los bienes
sutuarios ontuosos que se venden aquí
como autos de alta gama el narcotráfico
y sus consecuencias Siguen sin poder ser
contrarrestados por el gobierno Rosario
es la ciudad más peligrosa de Argentina
con 22 asesinatos por cada 100.000
habitantes y con casi un homicidio por
día